goosebumps haunted Halloween takes us on
a new monster filled journey with slappy
the ventriloquist dummy getting up to
all kinds of mischief again
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm revealing the secret truth
about slappy and goosebumps - including
loads of freaky facts you need to know
about the movie make sure you stay to
the end to find out what goosebumps
author RL Stein appears in the sequel
and hit the bell to keep up to date with
all my new videos slappy the dummy is
one of the most popular characters in
the goosebumped series and although
author RL Stine was nearly 50 years old
in 1993 when slappy made his first
appearance and Night of the Living dummy
the inspiration for the creepy puppet
actually goes back many years earlier to
Stein's childhood as a young boy Stein
loved listening to his mother read him
The Adventures of Pinocchio not the
Disney animated version but the original
much creepier book that dark tale of a
wooden puppet which comes to life with
Stein's favorite book as a kid and left
a profound mark on him as an adult and
the classic British horror film dead of
night which Stein watched as a child was
also hugely important for Stein's
creation of slappy all those years later
by the way Stein says he enjoys writing
book starring slappy as he's a really
fun character to write because of how
much he insults everyone in fact Stein
even has a slappy dummy in his office
where he creates all his Goosebumps
books for the first goosebumps movie the
filmmakers wanted Slappy's face to look
like actor Jack flack because not only
did black star in the film as author RL
Stein but he also did the voice of
slappy however in haunted Halloween Jack
Black only makes a little cameo
appearance of Stein indeed according to
the real-life RL Stein initially black
wasn't even in the script for the
goosebumps equal because the actor was
too busy filming another horror movie
the house with a clock in its walls
apparently it wasn't too late in the
shoot that black found some time in his
schedule for goosebumps - so a small
on-screen part was created for him all
of which means that Jack Black isn't
voicing slappy this time so who is well
the new voice of slappy is provided by
voice actor Mick Wingert he may well
have heard in the animated TV series
Kung Fu Panda
of Awesomeness where he voiced po the
Panda another character previously made
famous by none other than Jack Black and
it's no wonder the goosebumps two
filmmakers hired Wingert and he does
sound uncannily just like Black I
thought that maybe we should do
something really fun right Papa I love a
good holiday sale in haunted Halloween
slappy is absolutely desperate to be
part of a family so when things don't
work out for him with a human family
called the Quinns
he decides to create his own kind of
family by bringing all his monster
friends back to life and how does he do
that well he repeats a famous phrase
from the Goosebumps books karo Marri
odonna Loma molonu karrano
in the books those magic words mean you
and I are one now and when they're
spoken they give life to inanimate
objects such as snappy so it's fun to
see slappy use the phrase himself in the
movie to make a whole variety of freaky
creatures and ghoulish objects come
alive in the sequel Slappy's physical
movements are controlled on set by a
team of puppeteers led by Avery Lee
Jones just as they were in the first
film and there were actually four
different slappy puppets used during
filming the first one was a fully
mechanical version with eyes neck and
face that could be moved by remote
control and a head that could rotate all
the way around 360 degrees this
particular Slappy's legs and arms could
also be moved using a rod and his
fingers could be placed in different
positions
the second slappy puppet was partially
animatronic and had a mechanical mouth
as well as eyes eyebrows and eyelids
that could be moved into various poses
there was also a stunt puppet that looks
just like the other versions of slappy
except it had no mechanics and was made
completely of rubber which meant it was
light enough for the young actors to
operate when necessary during a scene
and it was also tough enough to
withstand any force for that breaking
during filming and finally there was
also the original working ventriloquist
doll from the first goosebumps movie
this like the original film haunted
Halloween uses a combination of CGI and
practical effects including special
makeup and costumes to create the
monsters we see on screen among the
creatures that slappy brings to life are
a bunch of mummies and while you may
think their costumes look pretty simple
creating them was really rather
complicated and they were actually some
of the most elaborate costumes on set so
what does making a mummy costume for
goosebumps to involve well first of all
the movies costume department cut
hundreds of individual pieces of fabric
into strips then they aged each strip
after which they sanded them down and
finally they applied those sanded down
aged strips layer by layer to form a
marine as there were so many pieces of
fabric involved each mummy costume took
a team of people more than four days to
put together when slappy says his magic
words to bring some monster friends to
life in the pharmacy a mask also gets
attached the stores manager Walter who
turns into an
oh good that becomes slappy sidekick
actor Chris Parnell who plays Walter had
to spend more than three hours in makeup
to transform into the ogre that included
having a full foam latex cowl cover his
shoulders to the edge of his face as
well as having silicone lips and a
facial prosthetic applied and to cover
up any exposed skin a foam silicon hump
and ogre arms were also added in the
original goosebumps movie real life
author RL Stein had a fun very meta
cameo as a drama teacher called mr.
black who appeared later on in the film
waving hello to Jack Black's fictional
RL Stein in the school corridor and if
you're a fan of the real-life goosebumps
author and you'll be glad to hear that
Stein is back for the sequel make sure
you keep a look out towards the end of
the new film for Stein's blinking your
mythic cameo appearance a Science Award
presenter principal Harrison now if
you've seen goosebumps haunted Halloween
what did you think and who's your
favorite monster in the movies or the
books by the way I've got a new giveaway
for 1st man which is out this weekend
you can win this amazing wireless
reflecting telescope click the gleam
link in the video description to enter
tapleft to watch some more freaky movie
facts or tap write for another video
you're sure to like if you enjoyed this
I really appreciate a thumbs up and a
share thanks for watching and see you
next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers